Google cloud next 2017 has hosted a rich
array of talks detailing the future of
cloud if you didn't get a chance to
catch instant insights a GCP developers
guide to building real-time data
analysis pipelines then stay tuned
because here's the recap Google cloud
platform offers a variety of services
that you can use to analyze high-volume
continuous data strengths fully managed
services such as pubsub data flow and
bigquery allow you to focus on
generating the insights you need rather
than the distraction of managing
distributed systems for example this is
a real-time visualization of taxi rides
in New York City the incoming data
stream is managed by pub/sub Google's
global publish and subscribe service
with guaranteed at least once message
delivery this is a loss of data way too
much to be processed and visualized by
our client device directly to enable
that we need to adjust the data stream
in a way that's more manageable to the
client that's what cloud dataflow fits
in cloud dataflow is a high-level
service and programming model for
pipeline data processing in our example
we need to reduce the incoming stream
volume so the visualization can display
it in real-time which we can do by
creating a pipeline in data flow we
start with an unbounded collection of
raw taxi data from pub/sub and then
apply a sequence of transforms first we
window the data by timestamp and then we
bucket by proximity this way for each
window of time we can find taxis that
are near to each other next for each
window and location combination we count
the number of taxis and output that as a
new collection via pub/sub for our needs
we wrote a custom transform however
that's not always the case as dataflow
supplies a number of standard transforms
like windowing mapping and count both
the incoming and outgoing collections
are unbounded so the pipeline will run
until the heat death of the solar system
until it's stopped or until someone's
closed coffee on the entire Internet all
at once and because it is fully managed
the backend takes care of everything
from optimizing the execution graphs
spinning up VMs staging the pipeline
code to the VMS managing i/o with
pub/sub managing persistent state for
fault tolerance so you don't need to
think about any of that
instead we can go straight to the UI
that shows us how the pipeline is
working here the volume of our taxi
stream is reduced from roughly 20,000
MPs to roughly 2,000 MPs which is well
enough for our visualizer to handle
while data flow can help process your
data in order to gather insights you can
leverage bigquery google solution for
enterprise data warehousing using data
flow we can create one or more ETL
pipelines that ingest the content into
bigquery allowing us to perform queries
and analysis for example in addition to
the raw data we could also identify
rides to the airport and then run simple
SQL queries to compare the ride volume
and average fare between Airport taxis
in the rest of New York not to mention
the time-based translating ends know the
best time to catch a cab to the airport
and this is just a few examples to
inspire ideas about how you can use
these tools to gain insights into your
own data check out the full session
video to learn more about what you can
do with cloud dataflow as well as demos
and detailed examples of generating
instant insights using New York City
Taxi data and if you want more recaps on
great next content make sure to check
out the rest of our playlist and don't
forget the next World Tour coming soon
to a city near
[Music]
you